dans cette histoire là et il en fait
largement partie c'est pas un figurant
dans cette histoire il a un rôle
principal c'est d'autant plus curieux
que ce que je reviens sur ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure et ce que dit
très bien jean yves camus dans le figaro
aujourd'hui c'est que le bilan de trump
à tous points de vue il est quand même
pas si mal que ça en politique étrangère
quand il ya beaucoup moins de conflits
dans lesquels il s'était engagé il a
lancé des processus de réconciliation
notamment d'israël avec un certain
nombre de pays arabes
l'économie elle est globalement résume
mieux même le parti républicain
finalement est assez fort au sénat il
échappe
le sénat lui échappe de seulement
conquis 71 honorable qu'il aurait pu
faire et il subit lit il s'humilie avec
avec cette situation
en plus il ne fait que renforcer le camp
baden ou en tout cas les mêmes les gens
qui pouvait hésiter entre entre les deux
c'est une sortie qui n'est qui n'est pas
du tout honorable et qui va être
quasiment impossible à rattraper
alors on se pose la question de la
préquelle et là qu'il est la suite qui
va donner
quelle est la sortie de crise qui compte
va prendre ce qu'ils n'assisteraient pas
à l'investiture le 20 janvier
donc qui met fin à une tradition de plus
d'un siècle c'est un petit peu dommage
de la part d'un conservateur de voilà
deux décidé de balayer comme ça les
traditions qui était qui était plutôt
noble il ensuite on va se poser la
question pour lui de son avenir de son
futur
certaines rumeurs explique qu'il
compterait justement s'exiler si je puis
dire peut-être un de gaulle et tenter
voilà un mouvement de rassemblement
en vue d'autres élections mais on voit
qu'on est face à quelqu'un comme qui
fait preuve d'une immaturité assez
importante
le parti républicain peu sur quelle
ligne maintenant pour les pour les
quatre prochaines années
moi je pense que déjà le parti
républicain doit réaffirmer son
attachement à la constitution on parle
beaucoup en ce moment d'une éventuelle
procédure d' impeachment un peu
symbolique quand bien même il serait
amené à quitter pouvoir dans dix jours
pour se dédouaner un peu je pense que le
faire ce serait plutôt une bonne chose
pour marquer elle a aussi un signal
qu'on peut pas piétiner impunément les
procédures considère comme quoi je ne
suis pas avocat de de monsieur trump
toutefois là où je suis un peu plus
méfiant c'est que vous dites ce n'est
pas un fulgurant certes c'est pas un
figurant mais je pense qu'on aurait tort
de penser que une fois trump partie gelé
les conflits les fractures des fractures
serait gommer comme par magie je pense
que le tropisme est là pour rester parce
que le trump heist mais encore une fois
incarne plusieurs tendances plusieurs
courants de pensée plusieurs préjugés
plusieurs attitudes qui précède donald
trump le rejet de la mondialisation
c'est patronne qui n'a inventé le rejet
des élites américaines des hits
washingtonienne ce n'est pas trés mme
keen a inventé le rejet de l'immigration
non plus le rejet du multilatéralisme là
encore c'est quelque chose dont trump à
agréger des tendances idéologiques qui
sont là pour rester pour durer alors de
deux choses l'une ou bien on considère
que les tendances qu'il représente sont
toutes avaient bienveillante et dans ce
cas là pour les gens plus civilisée la
falloir trouver un moyen plus d'être
pacifiques de traiter les problèmes que
trump soulève
ou bien on considère que les tendances
sociologique idéologique 95 sont
complètement on va dire malveillantes ou
complètement inutiles auquel cas il va
falloir réhabiliter un long travail de
réhabilitation idéologique de toutes les
notions que le mandat de trump a attaqué
comme encore une fois les lieux le
constitutionnalisme américain le
multilatéralisme l'attachement à la
mondialisation etc etc
le libéral que vous êtes joe biden ça
vous inspire quoi
de l'espoir de la confiance de la
méfiance pas grand chose et à vrai dire
moi je suis assez le problème c'est que
hayden je ne connais même pas son
programme c'est à dire qu'on a eu une
campagne tellement personnalisé d'une
bataille d'égo sur qui fait que la
campagne de bayonne a été tout aussi
médiocre finalement que celle de trump
au moins la première campagne avait le
mérite d'être plus intéressante parce
que pour le coup il y avait des camps
qui mettait de vrais sujets sur la table
plus ou moins de libre-échange plus ou
moins un outil latéralisé dont vous
pouvez avoir un vrai débat idéologique
ici même même la presse vendredi m de
gauche et progresser je n'ai pas trouvé
qu'elles faisaient correctement son
travail parce que nous a expliqué que
trump et être un méchant pour très bien
mais ça nous dit absolument rien des
grands enjeux de demain et comment on
les traite je ne sais pas qui est by
donne je ne sais pas ce qu'il incarne et
pas vrai dire je ne suis même pas sûr
qu'il soit le messie que les américains
attendent donc c'est là où aussi il ya
une contradiction ou un vide qui n'est
absolument pas comblé par le départ de
monsieur trump quelques réactions des
internautes
nicole 06 ça ne donne pas une image très
positive des états unis françois hauter
âge lorsqu'on est homme d'état les mots
ont des conséquences
arias et une questions qu'elle pose et
je vous la pose rachem selon voies at-on
assisté un coup d'état
elle précise cela me semble plus
guignolesque guignolesque que je vais
avec autre chose
elle a tout à fait raison on a voulu
peut-être pour se donner des sueurs
froides comme ça
m une espèce de vernis dedans putsch
mais ça n'a rien de tel
l'armée n'est pas derrière ça aucune
corporation ou quand la police
oui mais ça suffit pas à l'armée on est
face à des individus en effet qu'il rêve
de vivre un tel moment historique qui
décident qu'ils sont légitimes pour
utiliser la violence parce qu'il
représenterait la patrie mais il ne
convainc que en réalité c'est une bande
en effet de guignol il faut le dire
arm est donc dangereux mais qui ne le
peuvent être dangereux déguisé en mon
fait
sinon chaque tacle entre le carnaval de
dunkerque un spectacle au puy du fou
donc donc en effet maintenant maintenant
c'est important en effet de dire que ça
n'est pas représentatif de l'électorat
classique on va dire de train et que
comme fergane le notez bien il faut pas
oublier que cet électorat là bas existe
encore qui a des gens voilà qui ne sont
pas les risques de sécessionnisme de cet
électorat
autre avis de même géographique au sein
même ce qui va les fractures vont en
effet continuer il n'y a pas de raison
de toute façon que les fractures ne
continue pas de de se renforcer
c'est certain maintenant encore une fois
ces gens là ne sont pas représentatifs
du gros de l'électorat de trump et le
gros de l'électorat ce sont des gens
plutôt conservateur parfois des perdants
en effet de la mondialisation qui
considère qu'il faut agir sur
l'immigration que le progrès n'est pas
le seul horizon possible ces gens là
continuent d'exister et je suis pas sûr
que c'est ce qu'on a vu auquel peu de
sommeil prom canalisait lors
éventuellement leurs éventuels kohler ce
que la cpi manière en effet c'était une
manière c'est ce que machiavel abeille
c'était les humeurs du peuple en afrique
avait une manière de deux comme ça de
vivre de s'extérioriser et là la
difficulté ces baisses qui l'ont encore
est ce que les corps intermédiaires sont
suffisamment puissants pour pouvoir
justement sans faire le relais là en
effet on peut s'interroger sur sur la
suite des événements lycée grex x/y 16
précise d'ailleurs des guignols qui font
tout de même cinq morts mais vous l'avez
diriger les diables peuvent être
dangereux et ils l'ont été au combien
pour terminer ce débat on va regarder la
réponse à la question twitter du jour
croyez-vous donald trump lorsqu'il
appelle au calme et à la réconciliation
un petit tiers
il croit et de deux bons tiers n'y
croient pas 70% ne croit pas à cette
parole là on passe au second débat du
jour qui nous vient tout droit de
charente et plus précisément de jarnac
et plus précisément du cimetière de
jarnac où repose l'ancien président de
la république françois mitterrand
disparu il ya exactement 25 ans emmanuel
macron comme le parti socialiste ou
françois hollande a tenu un sirh ans
puis rejoindre la maison natale de
françois mitterrand où il a signé le
livre d'or en écrivant notamment merci
en ce jour pour ce cheminement sensibles
à travers les visages familiaux les
lieux les livres l'histoire où l'on
ressent comme les destins se forge c'est
pas tout à fait du chardonne mais quand
même cher pitot c'est ce que vous allez
comme macron commémorer la disparition
de françois mitterrand
c'est la question que nous vous posons
une question à laquelle a déjà répondu
le maire de cannes david lisnard dans
deux tweets assez virulent il faut bien
le dire
j'avoue ne pas ressentir ce besoin
dommages à françois mitterrand est
critique
selon - fait beaucoup de mal à la vie
politique française et dont nous payons
les conséquences encore aujourd'hui et
le second la dimension spirituelle et
intellectuelle de l'homme françois
mitterrand ne doit pas oblitérer non
seulement les effets de sa politique
mais aussi son cynisme qui l'a conduit à
faire de l'exercice du pouvoir non pas
un moyen mais une finalité c'est assez
violent ferghana ziari vous commémorer
vous la dispersion de françois
mitterrand et au delà est ce que vous
trouvez qu'on a raison ou le président
république a raison de le commémorer
tout et tout dépend du sens que vous
conférer à la notion de célébrer jeudi
quand même oui j'ai bien compris ça le
vérité petit mot d'être d'être beaucoup
plus pierre si on considère
effectivement que tout homme qui a
exercé des fonctions politiques
décisives qui a marqué l'histoire de
france pour le meilleur ou pour le pire
mérite d'être commémorée alors oui on
peut commémorer françois mitterrand
comme on peut commémorer n'importe qui
maintenant il ne s'agit pas non plus de
sombrer dans une forme d'hypocrisie en
glorifiant le bilan de françois
mitterrand même si sans doute une
certaine gauche seraient tentés de le
faire mais comme je les dis aussi avec
trump françois mitterrand c'est un
symptôme c'est l'incarnation pour moi
d'une certaine gauche qui arbore encore
fièrement un peu trop fièrement
peut-être l'étendard du socialisme une
gauche qui n'a pas encore bien compris
le sens de la chute du mur de berlin une
gauche qui peine à reconnaître
aujourd'hui la supériorité de l'économie
de marché sur l'économie dirigé une
gauche qui est encore resté coincé aller
à l'est du rideau de fer de la pensée
politique et on en paie aujourd'hui les
conséquences puisque cette hégémonie
culturelle et idéologique de ligne
logis socialistes ou sociaux-démocrates
appelons la comme ça pour édulcorer et
bientôt si à l'origine alors non pas du
déclassement j'aime pas ce mot parce
qu'il sous entend qu'on vivrait mieux
avant enfin le c'était mieux avant je
n'y crois beaucoup en tout cas d'une
certaine de stagnation qui se ressent
quand on compare la trajectoire des pays
européens et des pays du monde ce c'est
alain peyrefitte je crois qu'il disait
qu' il n'est d'histoire que comparative
bien quand on compare par exemple les
pays émergents l'arrivée de tous ces
pays qui il ya 60 ans à peine comme la
corée du sud étaient des pays du
tiers-monde et qui aujourd'hui ont le
même niveau de vie que la france
on se dit mais quelle est la perte de
chance finalement qu'est-ce qu'on a
loupé ou est-ce que à quel point serions
nous plus prospère si on avait pris les
bonnes mesures si on avait fait les
bonnes réformes plus tôt et si on avait
été un peu moins victimes cette
tradition dirigiste socialiste que
françois mitterrand a incarné et qui n'a
absolument pas été bénéfique à la
situation parce que le social démocratie
française n'avait pas fait son bad
godesberg il y avait toujours un petit
peu des relents de marxisme dans la
façon de gouverner dans les 80 qui met
bien sûr mais on n'a pas fait le procès
de l'idéologie socialiste fait et
aujourd'hui savent ça la conséquence
c'est qu'ils envoient des partis qui
s'appelle parti communiste sans avoir
honte du bilan de cette idéologie et
françois mitterrand et la nostalgie
mitterrandienne représente aussi cette
cette glorification mal placé de cette
doctrine la note d'accor hlc le bilan
vous faites vous aussi de nom n'a pas eu
les mêmes livres d'histoire mais alors
mon nom mitterrand n'était pas
socialiste
il a expliqué on peut s'arrêter à 83 si
vous voulez après on peut être plus
honnête et ne pas oublier qu'il ya eu un
tournant particulier que c'est aussi
l'homme de l'europe et de l'union
européenne ne pourrait plus précise qu'
il y là il a décidé d'amorcer un virage
un virage plus rigoristes
j'ai dit j'ai du mal à croire c'était
par un homme qui était animée en réalité
qui n'est pas une vision particulière de
l'économie loin de là où aucunément
certes il a écouté chevènement mais
c'était pour faire du mal à rocard mais
c'est pas en pur cynique mais en effet
il extrêmement cynique c'est
un enfant de son époque c'était l'homme
un homme du 20e siècle avec un goût pour
la langue française pour l'expression un
certain machiavélisme pour l'histoire
avec des dents très longues un rastignac
quelqu'un c'est mais c'est aussi ça lui
a permis d'arriver au pouvoir de faire
aussi un petit peu la synthèse il avait
compris que la gauche n'était pas
majoritaire en france c'était aussi une
force mais socialiste non et justement
les socialistes jeu entre lee mais les
vrais si je vous disais ce terme en tout
cas tout est dit mais ça nécessite ses
portes se sont sentis trahis se sont
sentis vraiment trahi par cet homme et
pointe en mai 2004 pourtant olivier faur
françois hollande y défilent à jarnac
pour le comédien françois hollande
socialiste je suis pas combien
socialiste selon vous le dis je je pense
que c'est le moment que ce soit disant
ça exactement qu'effectivement il était
pas lénine oui c'est pas dire il est là
et il a incarné en effet et il a ouvert
la voie à cette quintessence de la
gauche sociétale et culturelle
il en était le parfait anglais c'est
peut-être en cela que mm macro a raison
de le commémorer un vrai revenir et
françois hollande parce que françois
hollande justement quand on lui dit que
françois emmanuel macron commémore les
25 ans disputation de france mi temps
voici ce qu'il répond c'est à dire dans
mon quotidien
oui c'est une autre époque mais mais
ça a été sans doute une époque qui a
permis de connaître maintenant une forme
de de l'indépendance des médias faut se
rappeler que c'est comme mitterrand qui
fait les grandes lois pour l'audiovisuel
du financement des partis aussi et de
protection de la vie privée même si elle
n'est pas toujours assurée qu'est-ce
qu'il ya de mitterrand vient chez
emmanuel macron d'être président
c'est dit et quant à jean luc mélenchon
lui dans loppsi va encore plus loin
puisque dans une interview il dit la
présence de macron jarnac et écoeurante
vraiment des mots des mots très forts
fergane vous voyez quand même des points
communs entre emmanuel macron et
françois mitterrand ce que ce que vous
n'êtes bien rachel peut-être des points
lorsqu'il n'est pas socialiste en
l'occurrence oui brune et être un peu
moins facile à manier mâcon s'inscrit
aussi dans une dans un consensus social
démocrate qui de façon et la social
démocratie c'est le parti qui a les
pleins pouvoirs en france aussi bien à
gauche qu'à droite de l'échiquier
politique donc il ya à la fois le culte
du dirigisme il ya la dénonciation pas
vraiment l'incarnation d'un pouvoir
assez monarchique centralisée mais qui
est en fait le le fait de tous les
présidents de la vème république parce
que c'est nos institutions qui veulent
ça donc je ne suis pas sûre elle encore
une fois que se focaliser sur une
personne 10 soit très pertinente parce
que on oublie que ces gens là sont
toujours le produit d'un système
politique qui les précèdent qui les
dépasse rachel l'a très bien dit humour
effectivement je ne pense pas que
françois mitterrand était sincère dans
sa pratique du socialisme entre
guillemets il n'empêche que à ce moment
là en france c'était quand même un
courant qui avait le vent en poupe et
donc il devait donner des gages à ce
courant en planifiant en augmentant les
impôts sur le travail sur le capital
avec toutes les toutes les conséquences
que l'on sait sur la croissance
économique du baril qu'est ce qu'il a
gagné à commémorer mitterrand et mad max
je pense que c'est un symbole politique
c'est un manière d'être faite de rituels
en même temps deux en même temps c'est à
dire que
commémore toutes les figures politiques
françaises comme vous pourrez commémorer
jacques chirac de gaulle
il ya très peu de rigolade appartient à
l'histoire oui je crois pas qu'il faille
y voir un signe si plus précis que celui
ci l'aurait c'est vraiment risque c'est
protocolaire chanceux c'est protocolaire
c'est ce que dit kris kross
doit-on le commémorer chaque année
franchement nicholl nicholl 06
franchement ces commémorations à la
chaîne deviennent lassantes il ya un
risque de lui très lassant à force de
tout commémorer on commence notre époque
c'est ça vaut pour tous la droite n'a
que deux goals à la bouche
je suis désolé c'est un héros de la
seconde guerre mondiale mais les jeunes
non seulement pas seulement mais pour
les gens qui sont aujourd'hui animée par
d'autres enjeux que ceux de 40 60 ou
autre et bien voir les gens de droite
dire de gaulle de gaulle comme ça c'est
un peu aussi fatiguant donc c'est un
petit peu la même chose
c'est donc c'est la commémoration c'est
la commémoration côté on regarde qui
rétroviseurs purement protocolaire et
una parte absolument rien aux problèmes
d'aujourd'hui maintenant on peut noter
peut-être un point commun si on devait
les chercher en trouver entre macro et
mitterrand c'est aussi le fait qu'il
n'était pas sectaire ils n'étaient pas
sectaire il a réussi à ouvrir on l'a dit
savait que la gauche n'était pas
majoritaire en france et et il a su
utiliser les gens qui l'entouraient pour
en effet arrivé au pouvoir et conserver
le pouvoir
en cent en effet il peut faire écho à un
maquereau on sait aussi que j'ai dit
qu'il n'était pas acquis n'était pas
socialiste réellement une barrière est
ce qu'il n'ya pas un peu de
communication de la part de macron plus
globalement politiquement là je pars
vraiment politiquement de recentrage
parce qu'on va chercher comme un symbole
même si c'est pas le socialiste on a
bien eu ce qu'un symbole de la gauche
c'est ce qu'ils nous demandent d'aller
chercher à gauche des voix en disant
regardez moi je me mets dans le sillage
de france comité en effet c'est une
bonne question est ce que vraiment il a
besoin parce qu'il est déjà liquidé le
ps
donc on peut se demander vraiment
qu'elle est maintenant on va dire que
mitterrand et on l'a vu sur les réseaux
sociaux
bah c'est le dernier point commun à aux
figures du ps aujourd'hui vous de la
gauche c'est lui qui fait à peu près
consensus et l'homme est en effet en
cela qu apparent quelque part ben ils
confisquent les derniers symboles de
rassemblement de la gauche et qui peine
justement à trouver un second souffle
mais vous êtes quand même les
commémorations effectivement l'abolition
de la peine de mort en octobre le 10 mai
81 le changement le changement c'est un
mot clé dans le lait dans le programme
en tout cas d'emmanuel macron il ya
quand même une certaine cohérence mal à
aller chercher de ce côté là pour macron
même macron c'est voulu quelqu'un de
très révolutionnaire mais voyez bien que
c'est un trek est assez commun aux
hommes politiques français
oui c'est plus pratique de faire
campagne en disant révolutionnaire comme
conservateur oui mais vous la corde donc
c'était vrai pour merci de le rappeler
c'est vrai pour sarkozy mi temps 12
tulle et je vais mettre fin à
l'immobilisme français donc chacun se
réclament d'une forme de progressis ou
d'une volonté de dépasser un statu quo
que chacun juge moreau mortifère mais en
même temps qu'il faut préserver parce
que sinon ça attirait beaucoup trop
d'intérêts catégoriels
donc je pense que macron raison ce en
même temps là c'est à dire que il joue
sur les deux tableaux il veut en effet
garantir ce s'assurer que la gauche
reste morte en présentant ses symboles
pour rallier les voix de la gauche ou du
centre gauche
et puis il gouverne comme ça au centre
en essayant effectivement de faire
barrage à toute possibilité pour la
gauche de réémerger en incarnant pour le
coup un socialisme et la démocratie le
plus radical ou plus gauchisante plus
marxisante ken qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui et puis il sait que
mitterrand en fait est un peu l'homme
politique
certains égards que tous les politiques
rêvent d'être c'est à dire que c'est un
personnage de roman
et on sait que pour accéder au pouvoir
aujourd'hui il faut être quelque part un
personnage de roman
en tout cas ça aide grandement et quoi
qu'on pense de mitterrand c'est quand
même l'homme qui a réussi belle
alternance en france sous la vème
république qui a contredit son propre
livre quand même le le coup d'état
permanent en montrant que ben non les
institutions étaient solides et qu'il
était possible de proposer autre chose
donc
donc c'est tout ça aussi c'est tout ce
pan de l'histoire que représente
mitterrand et que peut-être beaucoup de
présidents actuels
emre représentés mais ce que la gauche
ait pas quand même victime de cette
ombre un petit peu envahissant parce que
quand mélenchon lui même laisse entendre
qu'il faut commémorer mitterrand mais
pas par macron que françois hollande dit
un peu la même chose est ce que
justement on n'est pas prisonnier de
cette image là je rejoins peut-être
faire gamme de gaulle pour la droite
mitterrand pour la gauche me suis
débarrassé des grandes ombres comme ça
je suis pas sûr qu'ils soient réellement
pris en audrey jean marc parent
mitterrand je pense qu'ils le sont par
eux mêmes et parlera damas de deux
programmes et de vision ça serait quand
même un alibi un peu facile que
d'expliquer que c'est mitterand qui y
traînent comme un boulet au pied loin de
là c'est eux mêmes en réalité leur
premier ennemi on n'a pas besoin de
convoquer l'histoire est d'aller
chercher ses obligés d'aller chercher
l'achat mitterrand parce qu'ils ne
trouvent pas un exactement aussi la
volonté de trouver un ancrage c'est à
dire que c'est une gauche qui ne veut
pas paraître complètement déracinés et
donc il ya besoin de se référer comme ça
des figures mythiques pour un désir
refoulé son affiliation sa fidélité à
une tradition c'est votre georges
clemenceau limiteur en 8 août a fait des
traditions politiques intellectuels ti
malheureusement selon moi sont encore
trop populaire dans ce pays alors que
nos internautes
qu'est ce qu'ils en disent était tout de
même un immense manoeuvrier politique
certes kriss kross chardon bleu macron
essaye de limiter sans grand succès
richard j'aimerais que la france arrête
de regarder vers le passé avec nostalgie
et se projette dans l'avenir
adl des réformes de progrès de justice
sociale sont tellement rares qu'elles
méritent d'être commémorée c'est un
petit peu ce que ce que vous dite rachel
et chardons bleus qui conclut
parfaitement mitterrand était un
opportuniste avant tout et quant à la
question
8 heures
quand même heureux vous la mort
de françois mitterrand à 90% nos
internautes c'est très surprenant ne
commémorons pas les 25 ans de la
disparition de françois mitterrand merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci rachel
menace merci ferghana ziari rendez vous
lundi même lieu même heure pour un
nouveau point de vue présenté sur
lefigaro.fr et présenté heureuse
internautes que vous êtes par guillaume
roquette en chair et en os
[Musique]